brody you live in miami via israel you
work at one of the hottest nightclubs in
south beach very familiar shout out to
story story okay cool
um
group gang yeah um
you must get your attractive girl you
must get guys in the lamborghinis baby
let me take care of you i'll tell you i
mean what kind of stuff do you run into
being a bartender in south so being a
bartender um you're not dealing with
tables people that purchase tables at
store you're looking at between i would
say
three thousand to twelve thousand
dollars mm-hmm um for a table at a club
yeah well one of the things i would say
no no no no bodega shout out to bodega
um
well what they say is you're not buying
the liquor you're not buying the alcohol
you're not buying the table you're
buying the real estate in the club the
experience too okay so what are you
running and the story really puts on an
incredible show but what i'm working up
to is that i
get the general admission
so these are usually younger
groups of people tourists
um and i do get hit on all the time but
um
never really
does it make me think for a minute like
maybe it's usually i'm nice there's any
chance that a dude rolls up to the bar
that he can get your number any chance
uh if he charms me but but uh
i i don't mind giving my instagram
giving my number a little bit more
cautious the old instagram there it is
yeah and then i get to see what his life
looks like
sorry buddy i also think it's so um
counter productive just to like hit on
your bartender at a club with like you
know 200 300 gorgeous girls
from all these states in america where
they don't understand yet how stunning
they are and their power like as a woman
and they're all going to the club and
they're really only there to look for
fun
why are you hitting on your on the
bartender so why should they not hit on
the bartender well it's loud i'm annoyed
i'm busy you're busy i'm trying to get
my money like yeah i don't know you're a
bartender you've said you bartender do
you agree with uh with brody over here
uh why do you ever give your number out
or you know meet a guy at the bar being
a bartender yeah a thousand dollars i'll
give it out
what do you mean that's what it costs
if a guy hits you is like listen baby
thousand bucks we can hang out later
yeah i hustle i i don't got time like
really sit and talk yeah so what does
that look like a thousand dollars yeah i
know what that looks like very much
when he gives you the money yeah and
then i give them my number yeah or is it
instagram that number costs a thousand
bucks yeah follow you on instagram is
that 500.
follow me on instagram
how much would it cost
how much would it cost to get your
number i wonder what that means i don't
think it would cost anything but it
would be um
very attractive for somebody to like buy
me a drink or
you know buy your bartender or drink i
like that well no yeah
[Music]